we're just going to start asking each
other questions are you ready honey
I'm so ready I am let's do this get it
in Gumby we've been married to each
other since June 2020. but what no we
have not
yes we have but you don't know in my
head I was like 20 22. I heard oh you're
out of it I can get her some water I've
been married to you since June
no we haven't because I got the because
the last time we did a ticket I got it
wrong here but
babes I'd like to ask you a question I'm
ready we've been married to each other
since June 2020 but what was your very
first impression of me back in 2015.
I'm going to marry her
I just now and then in June of 2020 I
was proved correct
okay when did you know that I was the
one for you oh
I knew you were the one for me when I
was mad at you but I still wanted to hug
you at the same time and I didn't want
to like push you you wanted to hug me
yeah I didn't want to kiss you because I
was still mad but I did went too close
to me even though I was mad at you and I
was like oh I can be mad at someone and
not want to ghost them this is the
person for me like romantic I mean in my
head I must like listen it's a big deal
if I'm mad at somebody and I don't want
to touch them you're not going to be
around but I have to be around you for
the rest of my life I should be mad at
you but still be like I love you babes
but like don't talk to me for like 30
minutes but I love you so much you're
right yeah I love that it's a big deal
okay
um what's the most romantic thing you've
ever done for me remember that day that
you were doing back-to-back interviews
and you were like you started at 7am and
you were literally ending at 7 p.m and
it was in the height of covid and
lockdown and you couldn't even leave I
mean they were really back to back yeah
so I brought you the best plate of
pancakes that you've ever had and I like
I made you these really I'm serious babe
I made you really beautiful pancakes and
I like cut the strawberries in such a
articulate and like intentional way yeah
have you ever seen articulate
strawberries
um yes they're like a hundred dollars a
berry yeah they are and they're so
articulous
I harvested them yeah you did you
weren't able to harvest because it was
covered and locked out and I
intentionally
placed them and use the most romantic
thing I think so yeah too bad they
sucked
they were the worst pancakes I've had in
my entire listen Bisquick just leave it
at Bisquick baby don't try to make it
from scratch stick with the Dutch baby
girl who is our favorite celeb couple to
double date with like in reality
I mean they probably mean in reality but
we don't have we don't have one we don't
double date okay but if we could this is
oh this is fun I would totally want to
go out with Jen and Ben
I want to double date with Jenna and Ben
of course the afflecks
look how happy I got
Jen Ben you guys will be home for dinner
shut up it is not yes it is no it's not
yes it is how funny is it that you were
finally setting the record straight on
how to pronounce your name
is this funny so can you pronounce your
full name for us my full name as of
right now is Raven Simone Christina
Pearman Mayday but they're hyphen so
technically they're one name Raven
Symone is one Raven Symone is one name
Simone yeah I don't even call myself
Simone I know because I'm gonna tell you
this was news to me breaking news I mean
not I mean I knew it but I didn't like
know it my mother don't even call me
Simone she put it on there tells you
that yeah but that's the way it's
pronounced my real name is Raven
and everybody calls me Simone everybody
say Simone Simone come on come on Simone
I said I bet someone I'm Raven I've had
many different jobs in my career acting
singing Talk Show panelist director just
to name a few which one that's me
yeah my favorite of mine
I love this question I was hoping that
someone was going to ask me this
question my favorite job of yours my
favorite job of yours
no no okay wait my favorite job is let
me really think about it I think about
it babes because I think that the
commercials that you did in the
beginning of your career between the
ages of like three to five were pretty
precious daddy and mommy but then I'm
going to have to say that I loved the
period of time that you were on The View
so Ray Ray yes what's up because that
was like our romance yeah that was like
we were young in love we were in New
York City we were we were young we were
in love we were running away to Whoopi's
house on the weekends Saratoga Saratoga
yes oh my God that's when we got stuck
in the oh they're not ready for that we
have to keep that for our new Venture
we'll tell that story when we're that
but that was a really amazing time so I
think that um those are my two of your
favorite jobs now
I work as a doula you do and it's um
kind of different than all of your jobs
but have you ever thought about wanting
to add that to your
list of things and come work with me for
a day I would love to be your assistant
as a doula it actually is it makes me
fall in love with you more when I see
you do your job because you are so
attentive helpful smart educated calm
and to turn on really when I see you do
that job it is
she did a uh
I think that you gotta watch that
because I'm helping women give birth
like turn your no I'm not talking about
the women I'm talking about you it's
like whoa that's my wife she's doing
that
what is something we've never done as a
couple that you would want us to try
hmm
okay okay it would be fun to take like a
cooking class together okay what would I
like to do oh you know what would be fun
it would be fun to skydive together no
I'm not doing it that's why it would be
fun it would be fun because neither of
us would do it but the build up to it
and on camera and the amount that I
would laugh at seeing you be terrified
okay
where do you see us in 10 years
personally and professionally personally
I see us reaching a lot of the goals
that we set forth for ourselves
I see us with a family
and personally I see
I see a lot of growth spiritually and
like really like really doing well in
therapy together I see great therapy
sessions uh professionally I see us with
multiple projects and I'm directing your
producing I see
I see content that we wished we had as
kids that we know we feel is missing in
this industry now
um and I feel like
what we're going to do we'll fill a void
in a certain way because we have a
different mindset babes with your powers
combined
we are Captain Planet the power is yours
I love you I love you too Happy
Valentine's Day oh that's right
Valentine's Day I didn't get you
anything
but I gave you love of my life go team
but you know what I think now after
doing this I think that we should
have a show on UT I think we should take
some jobs
um we should do this forever I think I
could just ask you so many more
questions I want more of these yeah me
too I could keep going and going I think
we did really well I think we did
extremely well I think that we could
definitely have a show on ET if
necessary 100 I see I see the names
behind us already
[Music]
thank you